if is there anything you want to say in
regards to the reception of the game you
are we already talked about it but I
guess more in the vein of like we're
giving you Game of the Year I know
that's not you know I'm sure it's
flattering but extremely flattering yeah
I mean I think we're very grateful and
relieved at the at the at the general
reception because yeah was it was I
suppose risky or scary at times and we
took certain decisions but I think like
I say I mean like I said before the game
we felt the game needed to feel a
certain way and everything needed to
kind of support those ideas and so it
meant committing to certain ideas and we
we did sort of constantly evaluate how
long it was taking to do things and the
pacing of things but we had to commit to
those ideas I think to give a real sense
of place and you know I don't know if we
got the balance right everywhere but we
certainly we certainly were aware of the
decisions we were making and why we were
making them and so for us yeah the the
reception that we've got we couldn't be
happier with but what the most
interesting stuff I think for us to read
is where people say oh why did why did
why was this decision made why was this
decision made and some you know that is
what we really like to to hear about and
take that and consider it as we move
forward to the next thing I don't think
we could have made this game we would
have known how to make it any other way
than the way we made it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have all made mistakes over the years
Jose every last one of us
but I kept us together kept us alive
kept the nooses off our neck
listen to me the time comes runnin on
the back this is over
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so by now people know that Red Dead
Redemption 2 is GameSpot's game of the
year Callie I'm gonna start with you
because you reviewed it what in broad
strokes makes Red Dead Redemption to
your personal game of the year because I
know you were also arguing for it
in 2018 for me it's like how every part
of the game interacts to develop a story
and characters so from the way the
open-world unfolds to what you can and
can't do within that world to how that
world draws you into the character of
arthur morgan specifically into the the
van der linking and as a whole i think
all of those things combine to make
something really special I've said this
before I I I wouldn't call it Red Dead
Redemption to necessarily like it the
most fun game to play of the year and I
think we talked about this like but
that's not the most important thing to
me and that's not something that I
weighed very heavily when I'm thinking
about game of the year and I think the
things that are like more laborious
about it more methodical about reddit
are things that make it really stand out
for me yeah like it is such a flawed
game when you look at it but like you
said some of those flaws are like
noticeably on purpose to make you slow
you down in the pacing of the world like
to make to make one like better bullet
you would have to do one at a time cut
him with your knife put it away
do another one put it away when you're
cooking if do one piece of meat at a
time but like those things within the
world and the fact that they like this
world itself is what really hit me the
fact that it's this responsive world I
really liked the game world recognizes
when you do things to the point that
like the game will remember things you
did that not even you do she'll go back
to like strawberry later on and this guy
will be sitting out front and he'll
remember that you had given him money or
that you had saved his like his horse
from a thief or something and you like
oh [ __ ] I remember that but he did
because I was an event for him and the
game cared that I did that obviously you
start to see the cracks kind of where
other people will come into the same
like spontaneous event but the game is
so artful in the way it helps you come
across those and the way that remembers
your actions that it's hard not to just
be impressed constantly and the fact
that it recognizes your actions really
plays a part because Lucy you can go
honorable or dishonorable
in many same ways that other games do it
like there are different endings but it
also kind of changes how the world
treats you like you were honourable your
first playthrough right like did you
notice the world kind of welcoming you a
little more yeah something like walking
through all the towns everyone would be
just you know tip the hat to me and just
being very polite to me and thanking me
for things that I've done if they were
honourable in the past and I think as
well to your point about how you kind of
see the cracks because other people
experiencing the same things at the same
time not since maybe breath of the wild
did I have that feeling of being at home
playing and then immediately wanting to
come into work just to talk to everyone
about what I'd experienced that night
and what everyone else had been like
experiencing at the same time and it was
also for a single-player game having
that feeling of camaraderie with
everyone because you're all experiencing
this world in your own different way
with something really really special for
me I'm in a real bind
Ellery even a bad way you could help me
you don't hate you okay okay calm down
where is he he's inside upstairs come
with me I'll show you
it was near Han I still seeing stuff
yeah I didn't catch on my playthrough it
like people are finding it online and
posting it on Reddit and YouTube and I
feel like there's still so much once
that game that even though I've
completed the story there's so much room
left for me to uncover yeah I'm trying
to play dishonorable in this save right
here on Xbox one and even just like the
little interactions I noticed little
differences the way Arthur talks the way
he though he talks the way he speaks the
way characters interact with him even in
cutscenes it feels like I mean I don't
know for a fact but it seems like some
even like really minor cutscenes have
been rewritten just to reflect the fact
that Arthur is dishonorable in this
playthrough Jake you've played pretty
much every Rockstar game and we have
talked about this during our arguments
that this is probably the least Rockstar
game ever made because of its like tone
and its story as someone who has a long
history with that developer how did like
the tone of the story and Arthur as a
character come across to you after a
playthrough and a half yeah I mean I
think that was my favorite thing
personally about Red Dead Redemption 2
is a lot of rockstar games are
pessimistic they're like black comedies
you could say like a lot of very cynical
mm-hmm and this game while it kind of
dips into that at the end which I think
makes sense because it leads into the
second especially if you're dishonorable
I guess yeah I think it feels I wanna
say uplifting because it's not really
you know but it but it it it's it's
almost heartwarming in a weird way
seeing Arthur develop as a character and
seeing other characters around you also
develop income terms except Myka Myka
sucks from beginning to end and also
like it's again like we won't spoil
anything because obviously if you
haven't played this game this is the
number one game we recommend you play
but the Micaela you touched on this how
the game's laborious mechanics as you
put it there they're there to like make
the world feel or the world is forcing
you to go slower into kind of like
inhabited and but also you find out
later on as the game comes on that there
are very very strong reasons tying you
to arthur morgan that they're using
those mechanics and yeah it's very hard
to explain without spoiling it but I
will I will never ever spoil that for
anybody whether it's like tomorrow or
five years from now because of how the
games
systems and mechanics feed into the
storytelling ending not just the
storytelling what games do that and
games have been doing that for five to
ten years the fact that they feed into
the characterization and the way you
inhabit that role is really like just
downright astounding especially toward
the end of the game yeah this was the
hardest thing about reviewing this game
was that I couldn't articulate this the
way I wanted to and it's still like I'm
not gonna spoil it of course but I do
think like this is the thing we were
talking about in debates with people who
are like you know I kind of fell off
read dead - I don't know you know I'm
it's frustratingly slow or whatever and
I'm like there is a reason to - all of
that and that is I think my favorite
thing about the game aside from the
journal I love Arthur's journal a lot
but that's another thing that builds him
as a character as a person it's like
someone you're supposed to relate to and
I think those mechanics like you know
the weight mechanic and having to eat to
maintain weight like that one I kind of
didn't appreciate and tell like I got a
little further away from the game but I
think all of those things like help
bring you into Arthur's like actual
emotional state in a way that not a lot
of games can do and I but they have the
potential to do and I I just really
wanted to when we were talking about
what the game of the year would be to
highlight Red Dead for that and
specifically like not just like I think
even calling it an open-world game is a
little bit disingenuous because it's
very linear in the way it unfolds
actually like I think I think what it
does with character is it smoked its
strongest suit and oh yeah I'm really
really still impressed by it I'm gonna
be thinking about it for a really long
time
and speaking of it's funny because from
the time we started previewing the game
several months before release up until
now it becomes increasingly clear as you
play the game and inhabit Arthur that
it's just as much like a role-playing
game as anything else in the way you
play Arthur obviously not just the two
meters like the classic Paragon renegade
kind of thing that we're all used to and
we have been for a very long time but
like it's not like it's not a
role-playing game in the sense that like
divinity was or like a lot of these
number crunching stat games are
playing games you are playing that role
as Arthur and just the way you can
interact with NPCs like and pretty much
every single NPC whether it's throwing a
beggar a coin or just telling the
shopkeeper - [ __ ] off when you just
don't even want to talk to him just want
to go pick up that can of peaches or
there's more verbs here than just shoot
or punch which I really appreciate did
you like we were you using those social
interactions throughout the game yeah
like I'm not only just because I was
playing as a good guy and it was easy to
build up that like this there's a is a
gamey way of doing it where you could
use it to build up your on a meter but
honestly I just felt like I wasn't
compass in that character so much that I
mean I remember telling you guys the
story but like my first night when I was
playing and you go into town it's one of
the very early missions go tell an uncle
in everyone and the game makes you steal
a horse just to show you how to do it
and then you ride out of town and then
you can bring the horse back is your
horse back friend oh you really were
just borrowing it appreciated and all my
friends had left me and I had no way of
getting out of town I could steal
another horse if I wanted to but I was
like I don't want to do that cuz I I
want to be this honorable good guy so I
walked all the way back to camp like a
chump but I just I don't remember ever
doing that in a game before because that
game made me feel like I had way more
like it felt like it was gonna judge me
on more than just a gamey level like a
game a fine level yeah and then that's
one of the things that I think enhances
the the times in the game where you
don't really have a choice besides it
shoot or punch like the fact that some
of those options are there throughout
the game and then when you don't get to
do that when you don't get to defuse a
situation because the mission won't let
you like I think that makes that more
powerful yeah and then I also like I
would walk through town and I would like
get a little too close to somebody on my
horse and I mean it would be like good
morning I am like I was I felt so bad
like if I use all right I was like all
right that was very rude of me you're
just trying to go back to morning like I
really was I was doing dumb [ __ ] like
that that is oh you know any other game
would be like a waste of time doesn't
achieve anything but I just was already
so drawn in that I couldn't not do that
and that's where a lot of the
frustrations from a lot of people came
from is like oh I just bumped into this
person on my horse in sans Annie
accident and now the whole town wants me
it's like you should have been more
careful I think like the game's not
throwing you into them you could have
slowed down yeah it's frustrating but
you should have galloped your hjortur
trotted your horse I don't ride horses I
don't know what they'd have been like
you should have pants her in a second
gear yeah got into first gear riding
down this crowded City Street but we
talked about how that characterization
ties into the systems everything but the
world itself in the way that obviously
the premise itself is talking about the
last days the outlaws 1899 the vanderlin
gang or the sons of Duchess Dutch says
sometimes like it is very much about
them trying to cling to an old way of
life that doesn't exist anymore and it's
funny the farther east you're pushed in
the game and the farther the story goes
the more claustrophobic it gets like
industrialization creeps in and the more
trains they're more cobbled streets and
I love the way it makes you feel like
the world is closing in on you despite
the fact that you come in this massive
city compared to like armadillo or
strawberry or anything the first time
you ride into San Denis I didn't even
know San Denis was in the game I didn't
think there'd be a giant city apparently
other people had already traveled there
but I didn't actually know that existed
until the mission were you riding with
Dutch and that particularly stood out to
me it was was like yeah we are
definitely far from where we're supposed
to be you're in these tight city streets
it's got like a green ugly tint to it
mm-hmm
it's gorgeous but as you're riding
through you can just tell like I'm not
supposed to be here and everything you
do there just kind of spirals and
spirals and spirals the fact that you
don't have as much room to maneuver
makes sense
I think Arthur is supposed to feel that
and I think you are to just walk into
that city like the because I also didn't
travel there before I was supposed to
and getting there and that first like
it's like a half cutscene it's not like
a full like thing when you walk up with
Dutch and it's huge but then you know
the the further east you get we're like
the as the game progresses and you're
getting to you
to San Danny in particular like you
really feel the difference between the
different regions of the game like that
feels like deep south yeah and where you
where you came from feels like you know
the Midwest II Great Plains area and it
feels so different from the first game
where you're like so clearly in like a
Texas area and I think they did a really
good job of developing the different
regions so you also feel those
transitions just anywhere you go around
you as you're exploring a certain area
and your camp for whatever it is I
thought that was really well done and
how much they were able to pack into I
mean it's a huge map but they like
really were able to make each area feel
distinct and then we just had the game
words the other night and probably want
my favorite musical performance was the
Red Dead medley yeah anyone while I was
on stage and he was like heavily
involved with the score and soundtrack
of this game but I think like the first
thing any of us notice in the previews
was holy [ __ ] the music's good whether
it's it's the the soundtrack or the
score itself like there are a couple
moments in the game that are very much
like that entering Mexico in the first
game like I I described read that to as
like a game built on moments like plural
moments like that where other people
will experience it but the fact that
like it makes it feel so personal to you
is pretty impressive what are some of
that your favorite part in the game with
the music wise I don't know if you could
say without spoiling having on my second
playthrough hearing the difference
between the music if you're a
dishonourable or honor Brandt is really
neat you definitely can tell by listen
to it like alright this is definitely
meant for a dishonorable Arthur but I
think the part that stands out for me in
terms of music is when you spoil
anything but just may I stand unshaken I
yeah whenever that song is used which I
believe is twice it's it works so well
it feels like in two very different
situations two very different situations
like at first when I heard it I was like
oh they're trying to recapture the
moment you go to Mexico and then when
you hear at that second time I'm like oh
okay this worked very well I think I
like the choice of music almost more
than when you first enter Mexico there's
so many times in the game you realize
that they were setting this moment up
like 25 hours ago yeah well time to
that's okay
and it's tough to like recommend like
it's funny like it is it is the game
this year I would tell everybody try yes
I don't blame people if they get
frustrated and don't want to play it but
for me that's what makes it more special
because in its Rockstar one of the most
lucrative if not the most lucrative
triple a developer ever and they are
making this like we've mentioned it
several times during arguments but like
I think it was Ramius Naylor on Twitter
said it's the most expensive indie game
ever made and that's actually like it's
funny it's obviously like it's an
oxymoron but it's kind of true right
like it sets up so many things for like
20 hours later but you get suit through
so much frustration but you're patient
and you kind of accept it it might not
be frustrating it might just be more
methodical yeah like I think the
frustration comes in if you were
expecting something one thing and then
you got read that yeah like like I said
earlier I think open-world game is a
little disingenuous because I think you
go into it being like I'm gonna be a
cowboy baby like I'm gonna go and stuff
and I'm gonna you know I'm gonna be an
outlaw however I want to play this game
and that's not what you're getting and
then I don't think that is better or
worse it's just like I think some of
that frustration can come in if you're
like I just want to get to the point
where I get to shoot a bunch of guys
well you're gonna have to wait a little
bit and and I think for me like that
worked really well but I would want
everyone to try it with an open mind not
it's not like you're little it's not
like a cowboy playground it's not like
you're gonna go in and have the freedom
to do what you want especially coming
from gta5 like it took them five years
to make this they haven't Rockstar has
not released the game since GTA 5 and
that game was very much a playground you
know like it had a story and it was a
good story but it was it was designed
for you to just kind of mess around blow
things up like go on killing sprees
whatever and this is much riskier much
more restrained and haste yeah I mean
it's like to me it's when people think
cowboy fantasy before the game out there
like before the game releases like all
right robbing trains holding up saloons
just like galloping through the Wild
West this game is about the cowboy
fantasy but also the slow boring moments
like just sitting by the fire at night
eating baked beans or
on your horse for what seems like
forever yeah whether in sad cinematic
mode or not yeah but also like the last
major thing I want to touch on is the
fact that it's a prequel to something
we've already played obviously and that
is a huge deal again we don't spoil
anything but Kelly you mentioned in your
review and like whether you even played
the first game or not I think the fact
that it can lead up to you meet certain
characters and you already know some of
their fates whether like a we don't the
point out specific characters but the
fact that I can set up the first game
which was from eight years ago and still
be just as impactful is pretty powerful
because Lucy remember you were doing
that story recap yeah so you were you
came off the first game pretty fresh and
Kelly you just like replayed it for the
first time like right before Red Dead 2
came out so like I think that's pretty
important because going to read that to
you know a lot of what's gonna happen
but how they get there is pretty
powerful
so the first Red Dead Redemption is one
of my favorite games of all time and so
I was approaching the prequel sequel
companion piece but I people want to
call it with a lot of trepidation really
because not only did I really enjoy that
game at the time like that was eight
years ago and I've had eight years of
just having such fond memories of it and
just basically my love for it growing
even more because you know you could the
Rose tinted glasses and everything so I
was kind of worried with what they would
do and obviously I think the biggest
change is not only just having John
there because you you feel like you know
John so well by the end of our dev
Redemption and to have him in such a
different light through the eyes of
other people that was such a clever link
between the two games I feel and also
the fact that you did know the fates of
a lot of the characters and you would
know what would happen in the way that
you had all these emotional moments that
were actually kind of subtle like I
don't think I would have kind of
realized half of them if I hadn't been
so deep in the first game as recently as
I have been yeah I mean I think like you
can play this game without having played
the first game because I'm games like
Arthur stands on his own as a character
there's a lot of development of the gang
but there's an incredible amount of
tension
in knowing what happens and I think this
is something people thought I was being
spoiler in my review but I was just
saying you know what happens at the end
of Red Dead Redemption 1 if you know
what happens then it it takes on an
entirely new meaning some of these
events and there's things that would be
heartwarming they're bittersweet and
there are things that I think would have
been more upsetting if I had known like
like I don't want to give the specific
example I'm thinking of but you probably
you probably know what I'm talking about
there's one character where it's like
they could have died but I was like well
I know they don't die so I that mission
took on a different like I was like more
chill about it like I get to appreciate
the little moments of this mission
because I know there's no rush because I
know this person lives so like I think
that it just allowed me to see things in
a way that appreciate things that mm can
take on a double meaning in this game
but I was also so attached to John after
playing the first game so soon before I
got read dead 2 that at first I was a
little like who's this Arthur guy I
really like came around on Arthur and I
I love him for who he is on his own as a
character yeah I mean that was a big
concern of mine was that I loved John
Marston so much his voice became iconic
and he wasn't in anything else he was
just in Red Dead Redemption and just
went quiet until this game came out and
I was pretty bummed initially that we'd
be playing as someone else and I did not
think I'd like I mean I figured I'd grow
to like Arthur Morgan but I did not
think I'd like him nearly as much as I
like John but somehow he surpassed that
and I think that you know once again
shows how sharp their writing is yeah I
mean John had like his own arc and how
his character changed in my direction
one but now I appreciate him even more
as a character because you see how he
changed from the begin from when you
seem at the beginning of Red Dead - and
that's just you know that's one
character over almost 10 years it was
just kind of insane in the first game
later on chronologically he's this
badass like outlaws and all he's not
technically well he kind of is now
obviously that's a big can of worms but
like he's this like lone wanderer guy
but then you go back to Red Dead - and
he's like the punching bag of the gang
that everybody rips on and like he's
god we have to go save John again it's
so awesome seeing him get from that to
the person that you see at the end of
read that one it was pretty powerful and
I don't know that they could have done
that if it was just bull they definitely
could have done that if house was just a
sequel I think it's more impressive in
some ways that they pulled it off with a
prequel I never thought I'd say this but
it's good to see you Arthur Morgan
all-in-all like we said Red Dead
Redemption 2 is the game that we would
tell people 10 years from now
2018 it was red their redemption to
that's the one that you needed to have
experience it might not have been the
most enjoyable game throughout but a few
of us had mentioned certain arguments
the peaks were like higher than any
other games Peaks despite the fact that
I had a lot of valleys like other games
could have been like semi high during
the whole thing but yeah I mean it
wasn't torture to play like I don't
think it's like I was like I can't
believe I'm playing this game and I was
like I'm glad I did that you know like I
just think like there's some things that
seemed to be pain points for more people
I think it was a more divisive game than
some other games but like I don't want
anyone to think it's like a huge slaw
anything I think it's just slow and
takes patience yeah and I feel like it
resonated with me more than maybe any
other game that I played this year
because of you had to put more of an
investment of your time and yourself
into it and I feel like that was them
the give and take I guess especially
waiting eight years I was more than
ready to kind of put that I was
perfectly fine with a game that took its
time and kind of doled out the story
very slowly even if we had to play it
really fast forward still had to play
really fast it's still like 50 hours
long yeah I got take my time yeah that's
nice for you yes it was very nice but
anyway if you want to catch up on the
rest of our top 10 games this is the
only one we gave a literal ranking to
this is our number one but there are
nine other games this year that we have
just in a general top 10 including god
of war which we mentioned including
several other games go check that out on
GameSpot we'll be talking about those
throughout the coming weeks and in some
cases probably throughout the coming
years like we've read that - we'll see
you then we'll see you around stay tuned
it always seems to be more more and more
civilization I want to get back in the
helping country of the West er what's
left of it leaving that ain't the way I
remember it
[Music]
you